[Musica]
nella vita non bisogna temere nulla
bisogna solo capire queste sono le
parole di marie curie una donna che ha
vinto il premio nobel è già il fatto che
una donna vincesse un premio nobel è
stato rivoluzionario e ora vorrei
proporre queste sue parole per
affrontare in modo altrettanto
rivoluzionario un tema che è quello dei
migranti provare a spegnere questo
rumore di sottofondo che c'è
costantemente di quando quando parliamo
di questo argomento e provare avere un
approccio che ci aiuti a capire con i
dati con le formazioni open data big
data e quindi da qui partiamo 48 48 sono
i milioni di ragazzi ragazze minori che
lasciano le loro case per la guerra per
la fame per i cambiamenti climatici e si
allontanano di questi 17 milioni si
allontanano e vanno in un luogo sicuro
all'interno del loro paese il luogo più
vicino che gli consenta il prima
possibile di ritornare a casa
questo è l'obiettivo 11 milioni invece
lasciano il loro paese e trovano un
luogo sicuro nei paesi vicini anche loro
cercano un luogo sicuro vicino e che
consenta poi di ritornare a casa 20
milioni invece partono iniziano un
viaggio a volte molto molto lungo 3 è
triplicato negli ultimi dieci anni il
numero di ragazzi di minori che partono
quindi è un fenomeno in crescita un
fenomeno strutturale
un fenomeno che coinvolge il nostro
pianeta e quindi come tale dobbiamo
imparare ad affrontarlo e quindi
ripartiamo dal viaggio il viaggio di
tanti ragazzi e tante ragazze che
partono molto spesso da soli senza un
adulto di riferimento hanno 14 15 anni
a volte sono anche più piccoli partono
che hanno 11 12 anni e da soli
attraversano migliaia di chilometri nel
deserto
c'è tanta paura
c'è fame sete c'è violenza sono
accompagnati in questo loro viaggio da
dei trafficanti
tante sono le tappe che devono fare nel
deserto finché non arrivano in libia in
libia vedono il mare ma non riescono
ancora a partire spesso stanno mesi in
libia nelle carceri dove ancora una
volta sono esposti a violenze o
maltrattamenti e trattamenti inumani e
degradanti
le donne sono quasi sistematicamente
sottoposte a violenze sessuale portano
poi con sé nel viaggio gravidanze non
desiderate e poi forse perché qualcuno
paga ancora qualche cosa loro carcerieri
riescono finalmente a partire e se il
mare non li ghiotte dal deserto il mare
di nuovo la terra l'italia l'europa il
primo posto sicuro che incontrano dopo
questo lunghissimo viaggio di paura e di
sofferenza da soli
quanti sono torniamo ai numeri sono
25mila i minori stranieri che sono
arrivati da soli in italia in questo
anno il numero è quasi raddoppiato
rispetto all'anno scorso
quindi si è un fenomeno in aumento
ci dobbiamo preoccupare dobbiamo farcene
carico i 2300 sono
i bambini invece che sono arrivati con
le loro famiglie
chi li accoglie in italia 10 milioni e
mezzo di ragazzi in europa l'europa il
continente più ricco del mondo
in europa ci sono 500 milioni di
abitanti e queste 500 milioni di
abitanti pare che non riescano ad
accogliere un milione di migranti
ora è come se un pallone non trovasse
spazio nel campo da calcio lungo 100
metri
allora forse c'è qualcosa che non torna
nei numeri forse la paura non la ragione
non ci consentono di contare bene ma per
fortuna non tutti hanno paura
bisogna riconoscere la paura e
l'angoscia di chi ce l'ha non negarla
non dire di per sé che sia sbagliata ma
provare a dialogare ad affrontare la
sfida e la sfida è che il mondo sta
cambiando e la sfida che ci pone la
migrazione di costruire una comunità
diversa da quella precedente e la sfida
quindi è quella di relazionarci noi
ognuno di noi individualmente in un modo
diverso e relazionarci con tanti ragazzi
e ragazze che quindi vivono nel nostro
territorio che vengono da lontano nelle
scuole nei luoghi di aggregazione
la sfida è aprire le nostre case con
l'affido familiare sono ragazzi senza
una famiglia oppure individualmente
possiamo essere tutori volontari delle
figure di riferimento che consentono
questi ragazzi di avere un adulto che li
accompagna ad affrontare la richiesta di
asilo a iscriversi a scuola a fare una
visita sanitaria è un mondo
completamente diverso da quello che loro
conoscono stanno imparando la lingua ha
chiesto loro di crescere molto
rapidamente
arrivano e di rendersi autonomi in un
anno un anno e mezzo
allora ci chiede la sfida nostra è
quella di cambiare è però di guardare
negli occhi questi ragazzi e di guardare
i bambini che sono ancora nonostante il
viaggio li abbia segnati profondamente e
consentire loro di continuare a essere
dei bambini ancora grazie
[Applauso]